my name is Katie Mack I'm an assistant
professor of physics at North Carolina
State University
and currently a Symons and we know their
fellow at the Perimeter Institute I'm a
cosmologists which means I study the
universe from beginning to end from the
smallest scales to the largest scales
how it evolves over time and how we can
explain what we see out there in the
cosmos right now
the most likely thing seems to be that
the universe will end in cold and
darkness what's happening now as we can
see around us in the cosmos is that the
universe is getting bigger
galaxies are getting farther apart from
each other the universe is emptying out
and over time there will be more space
between galaxies and there will be fewer
processes that form stars and form new
galaxies and the stars we have will
start to fade away the galaxies will
start to decay batter itself will break
down and the universe will be left cold
dark and empty in a process called the
heat death
this is like 85% of the matter in the
galaxy and the actual stars and gas and
dust
it's just window dressing and what the
dark matter does is it holds all this
together because without the dark matter
these stars instead of orbiting around
they're the center of the galaxy they'd
just be flying off into space there
wouldn't be enough gravity to hold them
in it's really invisible matter not dark
it's not black it's just invisible and
we can't see it we can't touch it it
probably is something that just doesn't
deal with light it doesn't do
electromagnetic interactions so not only
does light pass through it so does touch
like if you touch something you're
you're you're pushing your electrons
against the electrons and the other
thing and and what you're feeling is
that electrostatic repulsion and if dark
matter doesn't do electromagnetism then
it doesn't do that and so you can pass
right through it it can pass right
through your dark matter is passing
right through you right now and you
don't feel it but it's holding the
galaxies together
we think that is possible that if you
take two dark matter particles they can
annihilate and create something from the
standard model which is all of the
things we understand all the particles
we know about and so on and so if they
can annihilate like that then what
happens is they come together and
they'll produce some kind of shower of
particles high-energy particles and
that'll happen more often in places
where dark matter is really concentrated
so the power the Dark Matter
annihilation power is proportional to
the cross-section inversely proportional
to mass and proportional to the density
Square and that means higher the density
the higher the power by a lot and so you
expect that in places where dark matter
gathers in these Dark Matter halos there
should be a lot of annihilation
happening in the center and a lot of
these high-energy particles being
produced
these halos these Dark Matter clumps are
forming the first galaxies and the first
stars they're bringing in the gas that
forms the first stars and galaxies in
the universe and if something is
happening in the centres of these halos
if you have this big sort of heat source
then that can push the gas out of the
halos and delay when the first stars and
galaxies form